let's go to our next caller from the
four zero one area code caller from four
zero one who's this hey David my name is
Nathaniel I'm from Providence all right
go ahead and stand hey what's going on I
guess my question actually has to do
with Karl Marx and especially on a
little while ago on his 200th birthday a
lot of right-wingers and more
conservative people in the country were
flipping out saying that his teachings
led to a lot of death so my question is
is a philosopher really responsible for
his thoughts because in my opinion I
wouldn't blame Iran for alan greenspan
using her ideas on the economy and I
wouldn't blame Karl Marx for his
influence I wouldn't blame Nietzsche who
was apparently influential in the Nazi
Party so I just want to get your
thoughts on that you know the same
people that said that I'm sure if you so
that's like a very distant connection
right that the ideology of Karl Marx was
perverted in ways that led to the deaths
of people like let's assume you you
could demonstrate that beyond any doubt
I've got a much clearer example for you
after glenn beck talked endlessly about
the evil tides foundation a guy actually
went with guns to shoot up the tides
foundation is glenn beck guilty of
anything in that case if the answer is
no to that case then the answer is
obviously no when it comes to someone
like karl marx okay i mean you can I
would not call glenn beck a philosopher
but but what i mean that's like saying
that the you know this is happen people
say something that's grossly disgusting
and then they say well i'm a comedian
it's like okay well just because you
tagged yourself one way or the other
people still evaluate what you say on
its merits you know i don't know that
category is self categorization really
does much for us in this case i think
the bigger question you're asking is can
we blame the individuals who espouse an
idea for actions taken by their fault
actions taken by their followers whether
or not those actions represent
accurate understandings of their
ideology or perversions of the ideology
and from a legal perspective the answer
is almost always no unless there's like
a direct incitement from a moral
perspective it's more of a gray area but
I still have a difficult time jumping on
board with that okay
so one more thing would you then blame
any of Tommy Lawrence fans if they went
and stole food from liberals like he
said to do the other day I would blame
her fans if her fans did it do you mean
would I blame her yeah would you would
you up or do you think that's not enough
of a direct incitement I don't know I'm
not I'm not familiar with what your I
don't know what she said or what she did
I so I'm not really able to say she was
basically making a point about illegal
immigration telling people but walk into
Whole Foods with 15 of their family
members take food from a liberal and
then complain and then say hey well your
favor of illegal immigration yeah I
don't think she has any legal liability
there's people go in and steal from
Whole Foods you know they're committing
a crime and we've got a system to punish
them Nathaniel thank you really
appreciate the call interesting
philosophical question in a sense